das sieht doch aus wie in ein auto oder
es geht halt besser aus als in vielen
bürger leben halt wirklich das ist was
ich hätte niemals gedacht dass millionen
von bürgern stellen und 911 und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja dass
ich hoffe natürlich euch dieses gut
erstmal muss ich sagen tut mir echt leid
dass jetzt eine woche nichts kam
ich hatte irgendwie ein bisschen
blackout so für youtube weiß man das so
nennen kann also haben bisschen die idee
gefährt vor sohn gezeugt ja das war
schon wieder heute geht es aber endlich
mal weiter eigentlich weil wir setzen
uns kurz hin
jetzt warte ich auf die sonne so rollen
eigentlich dafür heute tatsächlich ein
anderes video geplant kann ich noch
nicht machen die sachen sind immer noch
nicht das nervt mich so naja ist aber
gar nicht so schlimm ich improvisiere
und das wird wirklich gut ich habe
oftmals von euch gehört alex ihm auf
jeden fall wieder essens videos und ich
muss euch eine ganz kurze forst um jetzt
zählen bevor wir loslegen es lohnt sich
aber dran zu bleiben ihr wisst ja ich
liebe bürger über alles ich habe schon
auf der ganzen welt so viele paare
probiert in amerika in skandinavien
spanien und so weiter also wirklich
richtig gute bürger nicht so
standarddünger wirklich gute burger und
er hatte ich vorgestern abend langeweile
und dachte mir was machst du jetzt
einfach mal selber im burger guckt mal
ob du daraus zaubern kannst dann habe
ich nach rezepten wie google hat mir auf
youtube videos angeschaut und habe da
wirklich ein rezept gefunden muss ich
erst mal sagen fox ist eine inspiration
also die ganze idee stammt nicht so ganz
von mir der youtuber heißt glaube ich
tasty finger von dem ich in der
beschreibung sehr sehr sympathischer typ
und ich habe aus diesen rezepten die ich
dann im internet gefunden habe so ein
bisschen mein ding gemacht wobei es
schon sehr den rezepten ähnelt dies halt
auch im internet gibt leute und ihr
wisst ja ich kann absolut nicht kochen
aber dieser burger der gehörte zu den
leckersten die hessen haben und den habe
ich einfach selber gemacht und deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht es lohnt sich hier
einfach ein video zum zu machen ich bin
euch hier super gerne kurzen bumerang
ein wenig von dem burger gemacht habe da
können wir schon sehen der sieht meist
aus wir kriegen hier heute aber noch
besser im juni
und übrigens ich mach zwei du kannst
auch mal probieren müssen wir nicht
hoffen dass das gibt es nicht dass man
sich viel zeit
das stimmt alles an seinem platz und
haben so habe sogar gratis dennoch
dieses börgerding
gekauft legamaster 10 euro gekostet ich
weiß mal ganz kurz die zutaten zusammen
wie gesagt wenn ihr die größten
nichtskönner seinem kochen so wie ich
macht euch nix ihr könnt das nachkochen
ganz einfach sagen wir mal hiermit an
eigentlich wollte ich mir selber so
dreyer spannbacken habe ich aufgegeben
sowie interesse und dann habe ich
gegoogelt und bin hier auf die vom
medical kommen wirklich extrem gute
waren ähneln sehr so wie man auch in
einem guten burger laden kriegt also
richten auch lecker ich habe dir selber
schon probiert kann ich euch empfehlen
auch nicht teuer dieser standard dinger
für 69 cent aus dem supermarkt vergessen
dass diese gut wirklich sehr sehr gut
dann war ich gerade das bei einer
metzgerei hat 400 gramm ritter hat
geholt dann brauchen wir noch die
zwiebel wir brauchen die tomate und käse
wir machen das ganze im innen aus teil
also in den bürgern eine super kette
also der bürger der schmeckt wirklich
wie dieser inneren bürger das ist
verrückt ich war sofort begeistert
du musst noch was drauf machen dass der
salat gurke mache ich nicht ich mag es
nicht ich mag eine salatgurke nicht die
kleinen küken richtige salatgurke portal
also in mein rezept ist das nicht mit
sich machen wir das machst kaufen wollen
jetzt erstmal mit der sauce die mich
auch ein bisschen an big macs so
erinnert ich zeige dass man sich von den
weg die sauce ist aber tatsächlich das
was am längsten dauert ich mache das
einfach frei schnauze keine ahnung wo 50
grad ca machst du es nur dass dieses
buch ist auch diese wenig ist kein
meinung könnt sind das ist ja kein bei
und selben pfleger das ist die soße die
auch in den outdoor bis sich höhere dies
heftig überlegst du kannst du dir
überlegen so ungefähr auch nochmal
gleich wie das verwechseln
und dann kommt hier noch ein kleiner
tropfen selbst zu
guck mal leute gebt euch das mal wieso
ist das perfekte muss das aussehen als
nächstes müssen wir ganz kurz die
zwiebel möglichst klein schneiden wir
schneiden ganz kurz hier die zwiebel
klein begann meine augen
also ist eigentlich scheißegal was die
zwiebeln end beim letzten habe ich diese
genommen jetzt das hier ist bei sonne
gemüsezwiebel oder so nennt sich das
wenn ich jetzt nicht ganz dem thema dann
heizen weil die fahne mal vor ihr könnt
so ein bisschen öl da weint nicht nehmen
jetzt hier einfach sonst haben wir am
besten auch funktioniert optimal drive
auch dieser junge her hier will save in
lübz noch zehn jahren mein burger laden
haben
das ist habe ich gar keinen bock drauf
deswegen komme es hier einfach hier
durch das loch schieben
das ist absolut ihren jahre trick werden
die zwiebeln brutzeln tut mir noch ein
bisschen butter dazu ja das muss das
motto das ist butter ist immer sehr sehr
wichtig ich habe gelernt in den rezepten
das ist wichtig dass die zwiebel nicht
anbrennen
ja ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen als ich
das zum ersten mal gemacht hat sind die
ein bisschen angebrannt war auch nicht
schlimm hat auch lecker geschmeckt also
macht einfach wieder bock drauf habt
aber wir müssen jetzt wirklich so 15 20
minuten rum brutzeln ziel es ist dass
die zwiebeln karamellisieren deswegen
gehen wir noch ein bisschen zucker hinzu
und auch hier passieren brauner zucker
das kann ruhig ein bisschen mehr sein es
gab leute die zwiebeln sind soweit
fertig kann man ja sehr schön braun
karamellisiert nicht angebrannt
eigentlich perfekt also so gut sind die
mir noch nie gelungen und jetzt kommen
die einfach hier in die soße mit rein so
dass wir dann hier jetzt einfach
verrührt und schon haben wir unsere
kinder in autos oder auch big macs lose
keine ahnung aber also das ist schon
wirklich sind aber extrem leise so kann
ich jedem film ultra league ich hatte
ich dann auch gutes fleisch geholt und
ich mal gespannt ob ich das überzeugt
ich mache immer 100 gramm pro partie
glaube das ist für den bürger auch
ziemlich nice wenn man mehr möchte
könnte einfach zwei partys drauflegen
das wohl mal so eine der 2011 eigentlich
ich bin da alles über 160 km auf dem
burger ist zu viel fleisch muss ich
sagen es sei denn dass gleich richtig
gute qualität dann kann man darüber
wächst im falle habe ich jetzt nicht
saubergemacht ist aber auch meist wegen
diesem stil aroma und auch vermisst das
ist wahrscheinlich jetzt aber schon ein
bisschen mehr als 100 gramm natürlich
können wir noch bisschen salzen und bis
jetzt immer könnt ihr auch drauf machen
man kann in der pfanne so ein bisschen
klappt quetschen damit er so krank wird
am rand weißt du das ist schon mal dann
kommt jetzt wieder ein bisschen samt
obendrauf ja ich weiß es ist sehr sehr
komisch aber es lohnt sich langsam was
irgendwie und jetzt hier noch christian
scheider käse einfach überlegen
das zweite tier zu mir auf jeden fall
deutlich besser gelungen muss ich sagen
das kriegst du dann okay dafür schenke
ich dir mein traum amazon bei dem
auftritt
alex fiva seine kasse über leiten das
meiste ist geschafft ganz ganz wichtig
ich muss mir noch die bands anbraten
oder an brutzeln ein bisschen einfach
wieder ein bisschen butter in die pfanne
er gibt ihr halt mal diese band schon
geschnitten agenda so und die kommen
dann hier rein sagt 12 kann man hier
einfach so ein bisschen an toasten das
reicht auch schon dass hier mit wohnung
ich will gleich seine ehrliche meinung
haben christen also ich bin so gespannt
wann das wird ohne scheiß da wird es
brutal und leute wirklich leicht wie
lange haben jetzt gebraucht 15 minuten
zum nahen kann jeder machen das
aufwendigste ist halt hier dieses
wirklich aufwändig ist das hier war ich
amateur krieg dazu wein und sagst du dir
aufwand lohnt sich für das ergibt ein
brutal ich werde fast nie wieder selber
berger bestellen ich werde mir die
selber machen außer vom feld holen
können nur dass eben gerade lhasa der
bürgermeister kommt das reit- und hier
den auch noch eben
ich werde endlich anfangen na ja das
sieht doch wirklich geil aus dass das
irgendwie zu dunklen konzern zusätzlich
keiner sollte folgendes ihr nehmt
einfach die unterseiten oberseite des
brötchens und macht dadurch ordentlich
was von dieser soße drauf einfach ein
bisschen drauf verschmieren juli mag ich
so gerne soße vor allem deswegen kriegt
er ein bisschen weniger aber ohne scheiß
diese soße abnehmer dann kommt einfach
ein bisschen salat wiederaufbau je
nachdem wie viel man mag
und nur kurz und ein paar tomaten auch
sehr sehr lecker zeigt und dann legen
wir das petit einfach oben drauf und der
decke das sieht doch aus wie in ein auto
oder es geht halt besser aus als in
vielen bürger leben halt wirklich so
machst du noch einen zahnstocher ein
schönes schönes plätzchen und so dann
mache ich jetzt eben noch kein hier
so aussehen haben sich von note jetzt
komme auf der kamera
[Musik]
dass sie schon ich würde sagen ich
probiere es eben dann kannst du
probieren ok ich muss testen ob ich es
gut gemacht habt heute also gestern den
ich mir gemacht hat der war einfach next
level ist jetzt schon ein bisschen teil
weil wir gerade bisschen wachsen gemacht
haben
[Musik]
was ist so gesagt hast du niemals gesagt
dass stolberg von pearl jam und nochmal
hier ist okay juli dann testen können so
gut es ist herzlich nach gut das ist gut
also fast besser als in den winkel
also ich finds ich muss sogar sagen es
ist besser als bei vielen bürger leben
in köln sowie gesagt hätte kohl nehme
ich mal außen weg aber es gibt das
schmeckt halt einfach wirklich frisch
und es ist nicht leicht
also leute macht es wirklich nach schick
mir dann gerne eure ergebnisse über
instagram total halt habe nur davon von
mir da ist so profikoch so national koch
wie sagt man dass egal ich habe überlegt
mit dem auch mal so ein hammer bürger zu
machen wir darauf gehabt dass noch nach
oben da abonniert den kanal und wir
sehen uns übermorgen wieder gibt es
neues video dann war wieder ein durch
video das war es dank fürs zuschauen ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen
haut rein